hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Q&A about history of Science
and Technology and I see a bunch of
different interesting questions saved up
here uh gosh where to
start was a question here from M rudo
about can I talk about the history of
quick sort or of Huffman coding well
these are sort of two
classic kinds of algorithm
ideas uh very different kinds of ideas
that both originated I think in the at
the end of the 1950s so that that kind
of time frame uh let's talk about what
they are so so
sorting is you've got let's say you've
got a bunch of index cards and you want
to put them in alphabetical order how do
you do it I mean these days you just say
well you just you know click on the
column header of your on your computer
and you say sort these things but how do
you actually do it well back in the day
people often did have to sort things
manually in order and I remember doing
that when I was a kid needing to take
things that were for example on index
cards and sort them and there are kind
of ways that one does that by hand that
are kind of feasible for a person to do
and then there are quite different ways
that one can imagine having a computer
do those things and I think the the most
common you know kinds of things one does
by hand you kind of lay them out you
start flipping pairs of cards so you say
these two aren't in order let's put them
in a different order you kind of doing
what in computer science gets called a
bubble sort where you're just sort of uh
taking you know neighboring cards you're
saying are these in order no let's put
them in the right order and so on well
this problem of putting cards in order
was something that showed up in all
kinds of places a lot of the early sort
of tabulating machines were all about
sort of counting things from Cards doing
things with cards that was all stuff
happening in the early part of the 20th
century before there were electronic
computers I think the um I don't know
the precise motivation for the invention
of quick sort but Quicks sort
is an algorithm which is kind of a a a a
randomized algorithm it's an algorithm
where you're almost you're picking
things at random you're you're breaking
the list in two you're sorting the sub
lists then you're sort of merging those
things together and it's it's sort of an
interesting idea that you can uh get
somewhere by kind of making a random
Choice and then going on from there this
idea of
Let's Make a random choice to see how
things work out this is the idea also of
the so-called monticolo method which was
used in in World War II for in the
Manhattan Project for using for studying
things like Neutron diffusion you know
you you try to work out what will happen
when all these neutrons are running
around in a in a piece of file material
and uh you you say well let's just uh
see what would happen if we were to
randomly pick which direction these
neutrons go and we have enough neutrons
that what will happen in actual neutrons
where we have lots of them that are sort
of moving at random versus in our
simulation will
agree actually this idea that one could
sort of estimate things by just doing
random choices um that turns out to be a
pretty old idea um I know that I happen
to find um a work by Kelvin from the I
think 1880s or so in which he was trying
to estimate things related to th and
and uh essentially did this idea of just
let's try a lot of different paths and
he talked about I think he used a dec of
playing cards or something and shuffled
them and and uh picked things and I
suppose this
idea that kind of Randomness as a way to
work things out that's something that
existed in kelvin's work at that time
that was a much earlier use of the
monolo method that I knew existed I
thought that was a method that really
only come into existence a little bit
before electronic computer
in kind of the 1940s type time frame I
mean there's other work that was done on
thinking about kind of the effects of
Randomness back even in the
1600s uh the boues and so on were
studying games of chance and trying to
make and trying to sort of develop the
early ideas of probability Theory and
again it was even though you've got
probabilities and random things
happening you can make definite overall
statements but using that as a way to
actually calculate an exact result that
was something that I think didn't really
emerge I mean again Kelvin and what he
did and the monolo method was sort of
doing that you can sort of estimate uh
things by just taking a bunch of random
random choices and looking at their
average but quick sort is yet a
different idea where you're just sort of
picking something at random and then uh
getting an exact results of how the list
should be is is sorted um even though
the algorithm by which you get there
involves Randomness now there are plenty
of other algorithms in modern times that
involve all sorts of Randomness there
are random ways to estimate whether the
numbers are prime where you're kind of
getting the the final result right you
there are ways of of trying to figure
out things where you're sort of trying
to find a path through a graph or trying
to prove a theorem and so on where in
the end you get sort of an exact result
but where you pick something at random
to do it I think the um I think it was
probably 1959 1960 is time frame that
quick sort was invented by chap called
Tony who's still around and who
I've been meaning to uh have an
interaction with actually um I believe
he was working at a company called
Elliot Brothers which was a company that
I'm more familiar with than I might be
because it's a company that um ended up
getting into the computer business in
England um and uh actually made a
computer the Elliot 903 which was the
first computer that I used back in 1973
or so
Elliot Brothers actually was a a
scientific instrument maker that had
existed probably since the beginning of
the 20th century making all sorts of uh
uh things they probably made slide rules
and stuff like that um but anyway they
got into computers and uh one of the
people who worked there was the chap
called Tony who was sort of a
mathematically inclined person who ended
up inventing this quick sort method um
the uh so so that's that's the story of
that uh Huffman coding boy you guys are
really testing my memory um the uh sort
of the the origin of that story had to
do with the question of when you're
sending messages how much redundancy is
there in that message so when you have a
piece of English text you know it's a
pretty good guess that if you have a Q
you're going to follow it with a u so
you don't really need that U after the Q
and actually more than that if you take
a piece of English text and you start
just blacking out
letters one can still pretty much read
that text when you black out up to about
half the letters you can kind of guess
what the words were just by seeing what
the pattern of of letters was even
though a bunch of them have been blacked
out so what happened in during Second
World War uh people were very interested
in that question because it had to do
with if you're trying to do crypto
analysis if you're trying to uh sort of
break a code you want to know if you
start filling in if you if you get sort
of a candidate for what The Unbroken
code is is that plausible or not and and
how much do you need to know of the in
order to be able to figure out whether
you are successfully breaking the code
how much if if if what you get you say
I've got a key for the code you get a
bunch of sequence of letters that
sequence of letters couldn't possibly be
English even if because the the kind of
statistics of the letters are wrong then
you say oh that's not the right key let
me go on to the next key and so sort of
a sort of an idea of crypto analysis is
you keep going until you get something
you don't know what the actual message
was but you can ask whether what you get
out is statistically plausible to be the
message and that idea and this question
of sort of how much data do you need if
if you're going to be able to figure out
a key of a certain length how much uh
how much text do you need to even be
able to know that you got that key right
and how much could you if if you didn't
uh and so that that turned into during
World War II Claude Shannon was working
at Bell labs and was working on uh
Speech encipherment uh there's sort of a
mysterious meeting that happened at at
Bell Labs which was then based in New
York City between Alan Turing and Claude
Shannon in the middle of World War II uh
supposedly to talk about kind of the I
think was called Delila the speech
encipherment system that was used I
think a few times I think um uh
Churchill and Roosevelt had a had a chat
over the en encrypted phone system that
had been set up uh at that time that was
kind of an analog encryption system but
uh uh somehow Claude Shannon and Alan
churing met up Alan ching was sort of
famous later after the work was not
secret anymore for having worked at
Bletchley Park and having invented kind
of a statistical method for thinking
about how to do crypto analysis and sort
of that that's what he did and meanwhile
Claude Shannon I think during World War
II invented sort of similar ideas and
then after the war ended I think 1947
1948 or something uh Shannon published
very famous paper
that was sort of the origin of
information Theory and kind of the idea
of that paper is to talk about you know
how do you measure the redundancy of
something like English how do you make
mathematical this sort of observation
that you can blot out some letters and
still roughly know what the words were
and how and for example another example
that Shannon actually used in his
original paper is when you make a
crossword puzzle if kind of any possible
sequence of letters is a possible word
in a language then you can expect you
can make a crossword puzzle where every
single uh place in the in the
two-dimensional array of letters is
filled in because after all any sequence
of letters makes a word on the other
hand if you have a language that's very
redundant so very few sequences of
letters make words you'll end up with a
very sparse crossword puzzle and English
is sort of a critical case because it's
about half redundant and that turns out
that uh if you want to make a crossword
puzzle in D Dimensions you need a
redundancy of about one over D to make
the crossword puzzle work so in other
words if English if if every Q had to be
followed by u a e d something or other
then with with very little redundancy
with very little choice you wouldn't be
able to make a crossword puzzle where
much was filled in because only very
very few sequences of letters would make
valid words but so Shannon invented this
kind of uh
method for estimating kind of what was
the uh the true redundancy of a of a of
a message or a signal and that was very
relevant because people were interested
in if you were going to transmit
something through phone lines or
something like this could you compress
the me message so that you didn't have
to use as much bandwidth as as many bits
in to transmit down your copper wire for
your phone line and and you know saving
the phone company money because they
didn't have to send as much data and so
on
and so Shannon kind of figured out that
if you have uh an alphabet for example
and each letter in the alphabet has a
different probability of occurring and
then each block of letters like pairs of
letters triples of letters and so on you
know the probabilities of all these
things occurring you can estimate the
probability you can you can estimate the
redundancy of messages by looking at
those probabilities there famous formula
some of P log P which gives you where p
is the probabilities and the sum is over
the of the alphabet or over these uh
over the possibilities for what the
blocks of letters you know a b a c a d a
etc um can be and so Shannon had this
way of estimating what the effective
redundancy of a message was um and that
told one something about how much you
could compress the message now people
who already sort of intuitively known
these things for example mors code
invented I guess the
1830s um was uh something where it was
making use of the fact that in English e
is the most common letter followed by T
followed by sequence of other letters
and when you encoded that in most code
an e is a DOT a t is a dash and that's
about as much a m code as I know an S is
a dash dash dash I think um the uh uh
that that so you're using the shortest
code word effectively for the most
common letter and so on average the
typical word will be able to be
transmitted in fewer uh
symbols because you're using the
shortest code word for the most common
letters and so what Shannon's idea about
information Theory told one was what in
English for example what in principle
the amount of compression you should be
able to get is and and that and so then
the question was well how do you
actually achieve that compression and
how do you uh how do
you and and and sort of the the notion
which was what led to Huffman codes was
this idea that you take blocks of
letters and you represent blocks of
letters by uh code words of various
kinds so in the simplest case something
like M code you taking an individual
letter and you're representing it by a
code word that is like
let's say a Dash as a zero and Dash is a
one and a DOT as a zero you're
representing e by just a single zero T
by a single one and then s by 11 one and
so on so the the idea of Huffman coding
is to do that for an arbitrary alphabet
and for arbitrary messages and to use
the probabilities with which different
blocks occur in messages to determine uh
which one should be allocated the kind
of shortest code word and so on and it's
just a systematic way that's based on
kind of making trees of things to uh uh
to develop that and it was it was sort
of one of the first practical ways to do
something like to to make use of
Shannon's information Theory idea which
had been used sort of implicitly in
things like Mor code a lot much earlier
than that um in in making compressed
versions of messages now in the years
since then people have come up with
better and better ways to do compression
um for example one very very famous one
is the one that's used in zip um so-call
lzw compression um lpol ziv compression
uh that that um is SoCal is a a
dictionary approach to compression so
the idea there is you just see what are
the complete words that occur and then
you say okay we're going to have a
dictionary and we're going to have
essentially we're going to say the word
and as a one word the is a two the word
rhinoceros is a
714 Etc and and we're going to kind of
just watch in the text that we produce
we're going to see well what actual
words appear what actual sequences of
characters appear and for those
sequences of characters we're going to
give them we're going to assign them an
ID where the the more common uh a word
appears the shorter its ID will be the
the earlier it its ID will be and kind
of that can be done sort of recursively
where you're saying you assign code
words for sequences of code words and so
on and that's what builds up lzw
compression which is which is what's
used for zip and and uh and GIF and Tiff
and so on actually Tiff uses uh Tiff has
many different compression methods that
are part of it image compression system
uh originally when fax machines were a
thing there was one of the issues with a
fax machine is you're you're sending an
image of a page or most of that page is
white and so you don't really want to
use a lot of bits to send something
which is purely white so a big part of
the compression that was done there is
so-called run length encoding where you
just say if you've got a sequence of
pixels or a sequence of letters or
characters digits that are all the same
you just say I've got a hundred ones or
a thousand ones and all you send is a
thousand zero and then you might say two
ones followed by five zeros and so on
and that's that's another form of comp
compression but there's been over the
course of time there have been a
sequence of different kinds of
compression methods that have been
invented famous One in recent times are
things called polar codes which are
quite unintuitive they take quite a
while to kind of think through what's
really going on in this in this coding
method and that's something that is
popular in thinking about I think it's a
standard coding method for 5G
telecommunications now it is worth
saying that when we talk about
compression compression is is a so there
there are two basic forms of compression
one is lossless compression where you
are using the statistics of the message
to send it with fewer bits than we're
actually in the original message but
where you lose nothing where you can
reconstruct the exact initial message
and the other is lossy compression where
you reconstruct the the thing for the
purposes of human perception for example
but you don't necessarily actually get
every single bit in the original input
and that's what's relevant for for
example most kinds of image compress
compression jpeg is a form of lossy
compression uh mp3 mp4 are forms of
lossy compression that's sort of a
separate branch which is sort of
irrelevant to to what we're talking
about here um but it's worth realizing
that when we talk about
compression when you say well the sort
of methods of compression that Huffman
coding was an early version of are just
using statistics of messages they don't
really use anything about the meaning of
the messages it's a quite separate way
of thinking about compression to say
well let me let me know exactly what
this message means and let me for
example write a program that will
reproduce this message so for example Pi
infinite number of digits in pi 3.14159
Etc but yet you can summarize all those
digits by just saying it's pi and or by
giving an algorithm for generating
digits so that's a very dramatic form of
compression sort of algorithmic
compression rather than the sort of
statistical compression Huffman codes
were the first step step on the on the
path towards this kind of statistical
compression idea based on Shannon
information
um the uh okay m rudo is commenting that
Tiff can also be lossless uh yes T Tiff
is a big mess because it is a it is a
sort of meta encoding it's kind of often
when people say we've got a standard
it's called blah and you say great then
we can you know Implement that standard
then we'll be able to Import and Export
files in that standard you look at the
standard and the standard is 500 pages
long and you know that it's got all
sorts of substandards and so on and then
you discover that oh there are these
programs that supposedly do this and
that but actually they only do a subpart
of the standard So when you say okay
we're going to export SVG for example
and yes some program we export to it'll
be able to handle that just fine or in
machine learning export onx for example
on an X um you know the it'll be just
it'll be just fine but then you discover
that actually this vaunted standard
people only actually Implement a little
tiny pieces of the standard and so a lot
of the sort of interoperability isn't
there but Tiff is one of these meta
standards
um gosh let's
see
uh
oh putz is asking about 5G let me not go
into the the the too much technical
detail I mean I I don't know all of the
technical detail but I do know a decent
level of it for for how 5G works but yes
it's 5G is a very digital kind of thing
in fact all of the the um uh By the time
one even got to 3G uh cell phones one's
really dealing with digital data and the
method of of sort of transmitting all
that data it's usually CDMA code
division multiplexing was what was used
for 3G um and uh that's something where
you're really dealing with
digital bits of data and you're sort of
uh putting together kind of in in a in a
cell phone cell right the the the what's
what's happening is you've got I I don't
know whether it's still 666 cell phones
per cell it always used to be that um
and you've got to transmit from the cell
phone tower to every one of those
different cellon phon and how do you do
that well one thing you could do is
allocate different frequencies for every
cell phone that's not how it's actually
done one well not most commonly done one
way of doing it is something that at
first seems very bizarre which is every
cell phone gets a different random
sequence of ones and zeros a different
their linear feedback shift register
sequences a different sequence that it's
allocated and it's kind of decoding
itself based on that sequence it's
decoding cing the kind of signal that
comes in based on that sequence and
there are these different sequences are
sort of randomly different from each
other and so every particular cell phone
gets to decode the message based on sort
of fishing out its template from this
stream of stuff that's coming from the
cell phone tower and each one is sort of
fishing out a different kind of template
but the templates are sort of random
with respect to each other and so each
cell phone just fishes out the message
for it and not for the other things
other cell phones but it's a it's an
extremely digital all ones and zeros
kind of
story
um the
uh yes somebody's commenting on sip
being a another one of these nonstandard
standards that's a that's an everything
standard and and a nothing standard in
the end that's a standard for Voiceover
IP type um uh
communication let's see Jimmy is asking
about logographic languages and
compression I think in logographic
languages well you know by the time
you've got definite characters you just
say I'm going to allocate you know that
weird looking character to this number
or this sequence of bits and then you're
often running again I mean in Unicode
the kind of standard for the encoding of
glyphs character like things and
languages uh there are there are uh
numbers essentially for the glyphs of
all the languages of the world
originally Unicode was just just
64,000 uh different possibilities and
and that was that was in the early 90s
when Unicode was being developed we were
a bit involved in that um the uh uh
there was sort of a lot of arguments
about um um in fact wol from language
was Mathematica were kind of uh some of
the very first pieces of software to
support Unicode um and we we actually
contributed some characters to Unicode
in the math section of Unicode um but uh
the the back in the early days of
Unicode there was a lot of concern about
well Which languages are really going to
fit in Unicode we got 64,000 characters
and for example Korean with its hangle
characters and the sort of block of four
type type charact type characters was
sort of big concern is it going to fit
in Unicode is the you know the 30,000
idiograms of of Chinese going to fit in
Unicode and and those things fit but
some languages didn't make it into
Unicode for example you know the K form
of ancient Babylon did not make it into
the original Unicode and and Ed a bunch
of other things and certainly Ed the the
you know only the very basic emoticons
made it into Unicode now that was at a
time before the whole Emoji explosion
happened um but there wouldn't have been
room in Unicode but you could have
represented you could represent I think
some maybe some Egyptian hieroglyphs
were the original Unicode I'm not sure
um but anyway what happened after that
time that was sort of plain zero as in
there were just 16 bits used to
represent each character then and a big
pain in the neck for software makers
like us to deal with sort of different
lengths representing different kinds of
characters back before Unicode everybody
always represented characters using
seven bit or 8bit sequences which means
you get either 128 or 256 possible
characters and then there was a whole
complicated zoo of different ISO
standards um of for different kinds of
characters so for example isol Latin one
was the standard that was used for
Standard English and it didn't contain
uh accented characters that appear in
other European languages it didn't
contain Greek characters it didn't
contain all these different kinds of
things and so for example what would
happen is if you wanted on a computer
you would had a file and it had had
Greek characters in it it was all Greek
for example then you would just say
those 8 bit sequences in that file
instead of being uh instead of the file
being encoded in isol Latin one for
example it was encoded in isog Greek one
which means that the bit sequence I
don't know what it is you know the bit
sequence that represents 60 or something
would be an alpha I'm making that
because I don't know I saw Greek one I
don't know it's particular encoding um
but in any case then when that f you've
got those 8 Bits sequences in that file
each 8bit sequence represents a
character then you say I'm using isog
Greek encoding so then I know how to
actually render that on the screen and
that was a bit of a mess because you had
to know for every file how is it encoded
and that's something you see in email
headers and uh in in web page headers
and things is what is the character
encoding and in wol from language we
have character encoding options and so
on um and that's um uh that's that's
kind of a a a way that that is specified
and uh so for example you know I think
there was isol Latin one through five
and different European alphabets would
find would would get into those
different isol Latin encodings I think
isol Latin one does contain a couple of
funky uh characters that come from kind
of Old English or NOS or something like
this I think it has a thorn and an eth
in it I think um that uh uh are not
quite you know that fit in the 256 bit
thing and and snuck their way into
isatin one I believe um but anyway that
that all kind of got cleaned up in
Unicode 16 bits accounted for most of
the current languages of the world
although some left got left out as I as
I
recall uh let's see I think chamir made
it in and I think maybe Georgian I think
maybe didn't maybe I'm wrong about that
I remember
uh sort of um uh very heated discussions
about Which languages made it in um and
which did not but that all got solved
because it was like okay let's have an
extra bit and let's have not just plain
zero Unicode but have plane one plane
two and so on which were represented by
extra bits that then allowed you to
shift in a whole another 16 bits worth
another 64,000 characters and so now one
can have kind of all the
all the uh kuna form which is sort of
okay hasn't really been used for a
couple of thousand years in in kind of
everyday life although it's of interest
if you're looking at ancient Babylonian
documents and tablets and so on and as
well as that you can fit all the Emoji
you want and uh that's been sort of a
growth
area
um there's a comment from Nightmare here
saying the future is going to consist of
languages that are just emojis yeah well
I I find that really amusing that it's
kind of like history does repeat itself
a good reason to study history is yes we
had the hieroglyphic languages and now
we're back because we've got emoji and
even these determiners in in the
hieroglyphic languages that say this
character means this thing as a place or
this character means this thing as a
person we're kind of almost back to that
with kind of emoji language uh back
again now you know 4,000 years later so
it's kind fun to see how that um how
that works
out let's
see
um well Eli asks when did the study of
Economics form I don't know the history
of Economics as well as I should
uh it depends what kind of phenomena of
Economics one is really talking about I
mean I think people would usually say
Adam Smith and his Wealth of Nations
book uh was kind of a uh an early kind
of attempt to understand kind of how how
value
works and to get sort of an idea of um
of of of what's really going on when we
sort of think about economic activity
but certainly people have been exposed
to economic phenomena and had an
intuitive sense of them certainly in
Antiquity I mean it's sort of an
interesting thing that in the Roman
Empire there were just published prices
for things so and those lasted for long
periods of time I mean you know a you
know a shark tooth or something there
was a price and it was it was on there
were tablets that that existed that were
just just the price for X now that's an
interesting thing because that sort of
denies the possibility of inflation and
you know I don't know exactly how sort
of the the Roman Central Bankers as they
were printing up money how that really
quite worked and how that was sort of
kept under control because what's been a
phenomenon of modern times is the
phenomenon of inflation uh where the the
effective value of money goes down and
goods get progressively more expensive
in denominated in uh the
currency I think people certainly
started making what was it an ancient uh
uh well I mean people say cus invented
money but I think that's more kind of a
mythical thing but um you know the idea
of coinage is very old um you know
minting coins out of metal is something
that certainly existed in um um well
certainly in the in ancient Greek
Persian times and maybe even before that
and in different parts of the world
different kinds of things were used for
money I mean you know in in Polynesia it
was cowry shells and so on I mean sort
of anything that is rare and where you
can sort of have some control over how
it works uh is is something which was a
candidate for making kind of symbolic
money I mean it's sort of a famous thing
that uh for for a long time people
really didn't understand the distinction
between the value of gold as in you know
how much you could buy and sell gold for
and the coinage that was made of gold or
made of silver and uh I think it's a
sort of famous thing from Marco Polo in
the 1400s I guess when he went to China
China had invented paper money and uh
Marco Polo found that incredibly bizarre
how can something that really doesn't
have sort of
in his view tangible value like a piece
of gold that you could melt down and and
use and and it's it's real value in Gold
so to speak uh was um uh how could um um
how could you have a a system of money
where the money was just paper and of
course the answer to that is well you
have to believe in the government you
have to believe that there is some sort
of force behind that money that that
guarantees its value now that same thing
came up again in cryptocurrencies and
Bitcoin and so on of well do you really
need sort of a thing behind the money to
establish its value or is there a way in
which something can have a value
abstractly and I think this is still
sort of a question in economics my own
view tends to be that as soon as you
have enough of a network of transactions
you've kind of established that you
can't you can't change that value
because it would change too much of the
this network it's kind of a thing a
little bit like what happens in
statistical mechanics in kind of uh uh
you you you have this kind of you have
this equilibrium where you've
established sort of the temperature of
the gas or something and it that that
that establishes something that you
can't kind of tweak with by making small
changes and and so that's in a sense the
by having enough of a network of
transactions you can have a meaningful
notion of value even though there is
isn't an ultimate thing down there that
you say is is truly valuable I mean a
common idea in economics is that in the
end value is associated with some kind
of utility to people now gold I don't
know you have to kind of squiggle around
a bit to argue for the utility of gold
uh because really gold is mostly
valuable because people think it's
valuable and and it's also scarce and if
there was you know if somebody suddenly
captured a golden asteroid I'm told that
no such thing can actually exist because
of the way that elements form in the
solar system but you know somebody
brings a golden asteroid to Earth and
it's worth you know a quintilian dollars
let's say then you know then what does
that mean for the price of gold I mean
this is what happened in for example the
price of silver backat several kinds of
disasters with silver people were like
the price of silver it's going up it's
going up it's going up and eventually
people had you know silver spoons in
their houses and they decided look you
know the price of silver is so high we
might as well melt down our silver
spoons and use that as kind of currency
like silver and that led to all kinds of
trouble with the um uh with the price of
silver which then sort of sort of
crashed as a result but this question
about when economics as kind of a
science really formed and people would
argue how scientific is it now that's a
big question of to what extent is is
economics really a descriptive field
that is just talking about the
statistics of what happens with the flow
of value and money and so on and to what
extent is it a proscriptive field where
you start from sort of some axioms about
human behavior and deduce what has to
happen in the world and I think there's
still a tension between these things
it's something actually I'm I'm
interested in thinking about and and I
think maybe there's some ideas from our
physics project that are relevant for
for thinking about this in a new kind of
way but the uh uh kind
of I would say the here's a here's a
funny story perhaps
uh the school I went to high school I
went to uh school called Eon in England
it's a very old school from the founded
in what the 1450s or something anyway
there was a there lots of distinguished
alumni of that school particularly the
the part of the school that is the the
the so-called College which is just 70
kids at any given time so about about
you know a dozen or so per year um
that's kind of the uh uh it was a was an
interesting group of kids
um they've done interesting the the the
cohort that I was in have done many
interesting things um but uh uh there
were lots of well-known people um in
sort of previous cohorts of that
particular strangely selected uh group
of of British kids but a story that was
told when I was at Eaton this is in the
um early
1970s um there was this day where
so-called thony day and uh the the idea
was that the original founder who was
Henry
the should know the sixth I think um had
put a you know had given some kind of uh
sort of funding to the school and it
said the the the people the scholars at
the school should get every year either
thant or a
pig and uh thant three old pennies they
still was I was there just after British
currency have been decimalized but they
still had they had at least in my time a
supply of old thoenes which they used to
give out on on this day but the the
thing was by the time I was there the
price of a pig was very different from a
thrippence thrippence is uh was three
old Pence which is um uh 3 24ths of a
pound and um which would be the uh uh
one uh 80th of a pound which is um uh
which is in dollars you know now well a
cent or two a few cents fact I I I
happen to just convert some British
pounds to to Dollars and I was sad to
see that the British pound is is falling
with respect to the dollar and it's like
a a I don't remember it's like on it's
almost a dollar uh you know it's almost
one to one
when I was a a kid for example that
these currencies and this is another
kind of economic phenomenon these
currencies were all uh had fixed
conversion ratios so you could memorize
they were $2.8 to the pound and it
wasn't something where you had to go up
to that you know uh airport uh you know
money exchange thing and and look at the
display which was changing you know
every moment so to speak um telling you
what the current market price for for
that current he was but any case back to
my story about thines so clearly by the
1970s thrippence and a pig had very
different values but it turns out
earlier folk who were at the same school
and this was a story that at least I was
told there were two young
Lads chap called har Harold McMillan and
a chap called John mayard Keen spelled k
y n s um and they were students at Eaton
in the early part of the 20th century
not quite sure when and apparently on
their sort of thony day um this Harold
McMillan chap was asking the John mayard
Keen chap uh you know how come you can't
uh buy a pig for threet anymore and so
this keen's chap explained that there
was that the value of money didn't stay
constant well ke became a famous
economist Harold McMillan eventually
became Prime Minister of England um and
uh that was um so it was at that time at
least I don't think it was well known
even even in the early part of the 20th
century the notion of inflation was not
well understood it was kind of something
that uh you had to be sort of a future
Economist so to speak um to to have an
idea of how that worked and I think the
there were sort of attempts to make kind
of a big theories of Economics like for
example Oscar morston was an economist
at Princeton who worked with John V
noyman this was in um the
1940s and wrote this book called theory
of games and economic behavior which was
in a very characteristic John Von nyman
kind of way we learn a bunch of somewhat
advanced math and then you know imagine
that you're just solving a field and so
in that case he thought he was solving
the field of Economics didn't really
work that way I mean game theory is
interesting in economics but it's
certainly not the be all and end all of
understanding how economic behavior
Works um so that's a that's a a little
um uh little bit on um on economics
there's there's more to say and a little
bit more that that I know about about
that history but um uh it's kind of like
even kind of getting systematic data on
what was happening economically people
weren't necessarily getting that I mean
in the uh there there started to be
stock exchanges um that was a thing uh
that was going I think in um
um the notion of kind of a a market that
involved trading
Commodities and and so on that was a
thing Insurance became a thing that was
a thing I think in the 1600s that
started to develop um there was a lot of
sort of high-tech put into kind of
financial Market making I mean a famous
story is that um in Venice for example
there were all these merchants who were
uh trading and it really mattered whose
ship was going to come in whether you
know you were you know you were trading
this or that thing if there was just
about to be a big a ship that had made
it in and it was carrying such and such
a thing then the price of that would go
down or whatever else and so one of the
things there's this big tower in Venice
that's still still there and uh this the
sort of the thing was people would run
up that Tower and go and see you know
which ships were coming over the horizon
so that they could be the first to trade
on that information and and famously
Galileo uh licensed the telescope to the
merchants of Venice um for their for all
terrestrial uses and um they were using
telescopes to go and uh uh figure out
whether that was around 1608 I think uh
16007 maybe um to find out you know what
ship was coming in who Could Be the
first merchant to figure that out and
you know Galileo and things in those
days were very litigious I suppose in in
uh in Venice and so on and you know it
was there was a contract it said all
terrestrial uses and so Galileo was like
and this story may be partly apocryphal
um but it's kind of a an interesting
story I I've never really checked into
whether the details are correct but um
so he said well forget about terrestrial
uses I'm going to turn the telescope to
the sky and see what I see there and I'm
allowed to do that and then of course he
discovered uh the um the moons of
Jupiter and so on and uh and lots of
exciting things happened as a result of
that let's see uh there was a question
here
about from prab about the history of
Double Entry
bookkeeping um I mean Double Entry
bookkeeping is usually attributed to
Luca pacholi friend of Leonardo D
Vinci's um in uh in Italy um uh I don't
know
the I I think it was sort of a a
very this whole idea that sort of
mathematicians were Consultants to
Merchants was certainly an established
idea I mean for example Fibonacci in the
early
1200s uh when he brought back Hindu
Arabic numerals to the West he was he
was based in Pisa in Italy and um he
um uh he was that was sort of a a a look
Merchants you can do better than working
things out with Roman numerals you can
use this positional notation of Hindu
Arabic and by the way I'll teach you how
to do that and he had this book called
Liber abachi the book of the Abacus um
that uh was about kind of um how to do
calculations and so on and how to think
about arithmetic in the in the um in
this hdu Arabic positional form it also
famously at the very end of the book it
has a kind of an exercise example these
rabbits in an enclosure and there's
rabbits and every year they have uh you
know uh baby rabbits and so on and that
was the feminar series defined in around
1205 I
think um ad by the way the Fibonacci
series was also I think independently
discovered in India um much earlier than
that as a result of an attempt to
enumerate the different forms of pro the
different different ways in which a a a
piece of uh of sung poetry could be
presented you know is it long short
short short long long Etc what are the
different forms that that there can be
and there was some kind of rule that you
couldn't have I don't know two shorts in
a row or probably two Longs in a row
actually um and then when you enumerate
the number of possibilities that gives
you Fibonacci numbers and that was a an
even much earlier use of of Fibonacci
numbers than Fibonacci with his rabbits
but the point was Fibonacci was first
and foremost somebody who was educating
the merchants about how to do their
calculations and uh the and that that
was a long tradition and Luca patrii was
was part of that tradition of saying you
know how would you organize your
accounts you know you're a merchant how
would you organize your accounts and
that was sort of something that people
were interested in for a long time I
mean I think lots of uh until computers
basically
it was it was really a non-trivial thing
to keep the accounts and do all these
calculations and you know in some parts
of the world particularly in Asia
abacuses were were a big thing in other
places it was really just people doing
calculations and for example ramuan
famous Indian mathematician the
beginning of the 20th century uh he was
sort of employed at first as a clerk at
the Port of Madras um uh now Chennai um
is that right yes that's right the
uh um that who was you know responsible
for basically doing the numerical doing
the calculations to keep the accounts at
that time uh you know those things
weren't as easy without computers um but
uh this you know there's a long
tradition of sort of mathematicians in
the service of of merchants and there
were a series of books that were sort of
the the the the famous book of the time
that was like I've got a better scheme
for doing this arithmetic and I think
those books were used sort of the
open-source approach to selling services
um and uh you know those books were were
printed after printing started up and
then you could go get these books and
they cost a certain amount of money you
made something as an author from from
selling those books but I think you made
more by selling your services of let me
come in and do a do a kind of a a
seminar or a consulting job for showing
you how to how to uh do your kind of uh
calculations for your for your business
I mean it is kind of funny that in a
sense nothing changes you know it's it's
there's still the kind of um uh lots of
companies that are in the business of
coming into your business and telling
you how sort how to set up all your
transactions and your databases and so
on and it's obviously the volumes are
higher today than they were back in the
day and back in the day you were
teaching sort of the merchants how to do
their calculations
um and there were lots of kind of
mysterious methods there was a chap
called Richard record who was the first
person who wrote known arithmetic book
in English um and he had the the method
of well I'm sure in English it was
called the method of Zeds the method of
Z's where he had some whole elaborate
calculation thing where you you followed
numbers in some P pattern that looked
like a a z and anyway there were all
these these things and and and later on
there was the whole you know the method
of Threes the method of sixes these were
all ideas for sort of how to think about
calculation um and uh it is sort of
ironic that when it comes to Modern sort
of math education there are these fads
that uh which would cause it to be the
case that if somebody explained to me
how some elementary school kid was being
taught arithmetic it would probably have
terms in it that I don't know even
though I think I more or less know how
to do arithmetic by this point took me a
long time to learn I taught computers
how to do it long before I could
fluently do it myself I would say in in
uh when it comes to you know learning
multiplication tables and doing long
multiplication or long division and so
I'm not not a big expert at doing that
by hand I I I certainly put more effort
teaching computers to do those things
but any case the
um uh that was you know in in in modern
kind of math education they keep on
being these kind of ideas and we can
explain it like this we can explain it
like that this is nothing new this has
been going on for hundreds of years with
different kind of methods that at
different times to a later to later folk
seem quite obscure I I kind of almost
think it would be fun to inventory all
of those different methods and sort of
import them into modern math classrooms
and so on uh just you know you get to
teach math history at the same time that
you um uh that you teach um um uh the
actual uh uh the methods of of math and
it's sort of I think relevant to know
know that these organizations of
calculation are historical they are
things that happen to be that way they
are not necessarily that way as a uh as
a as a as a feature of the nature of
numbers and the nature of arithmetic
they just happen to be that way because
that's a way that somebody thought it
was a good way for people to do it and
for example it might not be the way
computers do it you know for instance
the stand the long multiplication method
um the uh I remember when one of my kids
was was uh sort of supposedly learning
that and was like why why should I learn
this computers can do it and uh I didn't
really disagree but actually we had the
opportunity at that time to like try and
figure out well you know maybe there's a
reason to learn it because it's kind of
fun to know what the computer is doing
inside and it was like well what is the
computer doing inside how does
mathematic or morph language actually do
long multiplication and it turns out
it's not what you think it's not the
standard so-called schoolbook method uh
which is which if you have n digits in
each number takes n squar steps it's
something much more efficient than that
but it's something deeply non-human it
eventually uses for transforms and
things and eventually if you have a very
very long number it takes a time that's
sort of n log log log n or something so
a time very very close to just looking
at every digit um and it certainly
doesn't need need and squared time where
you're looking at every digit with every
with every other digit type thing um so
it's uh you know the the in that case
the sort of the the human historical
approach is is not the one that's
actually
used
uh gosh Steph Jones is asking what were
the early tabulating machines like uh
such as ones that IBM sold well there
were um
there were tabulating machines in the
late 1800s maybe even earlier than that
and they made use of
cards uh cards were invented I Believe
by
jakad um Marie jakad in um uh uh at the
beginning of the 1800s and they were
invented for uh for looms for weaving
and and kind of the idea was the threads
are being put in the piece of fabri in a
particular way what pattern will the
threads be put in and these these Punch
Cards where you had holes punched in
them there was a mechanical device that
would basically uh if there was a hole
then put a thread in this place if there
wasn't a hole then don't put a thread in
this place that's what led in the
1840s when adah Lovelace was writing
about babes designed for the analytical
engine um the analytical engine was
intended to have its programs stored on
Punch Cards of the kinds that were used
with looms and and a Lov wrote about
this and has this lovely statement where
she says the the um the analytical
engine will weave algebraical patterns
as a loom weaves patterns of birds and
flowers so it was kind of this idea that
algebraical patterns that was her term
for programs effectively and that was
kind of a notion of you're using a card
to represent this program Now cards were
used more directly
as a way to keep Census Data you know
governments like to do censuses partly
because they do things like organize
voting that way and because they like to
collect taxes based on those kinds of
information and and one of the ideas
there was you have these cards and you
would punch out holes in these cards
depending on whether somebody like one
card per person okay who has this
attribute who is uh between 50 and and
60 years old let's say Okay punch that
hole out of the card who is this age
punch another hole out of the card and
then you can figure out how many if you
have a big stack of cards um you can uh
let's see how does this work actually
you basically are are pulling out you're
kind of seeing well which cards have
this piece punched out of them and then
you're sort of lifting up the cards that
have those pieces punched out but now
that I'm thinking about it I'm not quite
sure how that mechanically worked I
should know that but sort of a famous um
the U the early sort of instantiation of
IBM was the tabulating company a chap
called Herman holth was uh responsible
for inventing at least an innovation I'm
not sure exactly at what stage of
tabulating machines and that was
famously used for the US sensus in the
early part of the 1900s maybe the 1910
census I'm not sure um and that was sort
of an early contract that IBM had with
the US government it still has lots of
business with the US government but that
was an early contract that it had and in
in as as various countries got to be
sort of more efficient and
informationally oriented they had lots
of tabulating machines used for sort of
uh saying things about their citizenry
and so on I mean eventually got used for
all kinds of terrible purposes in the
1930s and uh possibly it's it's of the
early version of endless micro dat
collection that's happening all the time
these days happening sometimes in in
some places for commercial purposes in
some places for government purposes and
uh it's kind of again it's you know it
sort of all started with a tabulating
machine well you could say it all
started with the original uh sort of
documentation of people and and things
in ancient Babylon kind of when the
first cities were being created that was
a time when sort of there was a desire
to get things organized write things
down have definite records have definite
descriptions of who owned what and so on
um and that was that was kind of how
that how that
went
um let's
see
uh
H uh hu asks do you think future
historians will have a harder time
passing through all the information
available in the last 50 years compared
to the last century or even two what is
the best historical record for research
books images video
Etc you know I've done a bunch of
History work and I have to say giving a
bit of a shout out to my friend Brewster
kale who runs the internet archive
that's really the thing that transforms
historical research particularly for the
1800s because uh the sort of all the
documents from that time time have been
scanned and OC you can search them all
the newspapers all these kinds of things
it's it's actually more readily
available from that time than from later
times because when things are in
copyright you can't make them as widely
available but the things that are out of
copyright and have been scanned they are
just really a gold mine for historical
research it's sort of remarkable to me
that I can you know there's the name of
a person and I can just do a search and
I can find out that oh yeah they were
mentioned in this obscure newspaper uh
sometime in you know
1822 and uh there are lots of
connections that I've been able to make
by just doing those kinds of searches so
you know I think that's an important
thing the the the kind of scanning of
everything and the digitization of
everything is kind of a critical thing
now when it comes to things like movies
and so on well we've now got to the
point where we have pretty good uh kind
of transcription of the dialogue in
movies so that becomes searchable we
have For Better or Worse increasingly
good kind of uh things like face
recognition and searchability of that um
in uh in things like movies so one's
being able to get a lot of kind of
searchable stuff in things in things
like movies I would say that the uh
there's a there's really a question of
more of well there's stuff that's on the
web there's you know some number of
billions of pages that's probably about
I don't know between 5 and 10 billion
pages of stuff textual material on the
web there's maybe a 100 billion if you
include all the archive material there's
even more if you include uh the things
that are in the deeper web uh behind
sort of corporate firewalls and things
like this um that's a lot of lot of data
and I think sort of threading that
together to do history is absolutely
doable I mean i' I've done a bunch of
that myself I've written both about
other people's history and about my own
history in the case of my own history I
have pretty good archives so I have I
really have the information I mean I
have for 35 years now I have really
pretty much everything every I've
electronically touched I have down to
keystrokes and so on and so it's kind of
fun I can say and i' I've done this a
number of times recently when I'm
looking back at discoveries I made let's
say in the 1980s or 1990s I can say
things like at you know
251 am and 32 seconds I discovered this
thing because I actually have that time
stamp because I have that Digital Data
to see what actually happened now you
know then the question is well how do
you tell what is the Arc of History how
do you tell all those individual things
and knit them together into sort of the
overall Arc of History I suspect llms
make that easier certainly you know llms
can do an okay job at like summarizing
like we have an llm running right now
now which is going to make a summary of
uh of all the the yakking I've been
doing here it won't be perfect it might
make some things up but it's going to
get better at that kind of summarization
I think I think that's one of the things
that we'll see incremental Improvement
earn and I think that that's maybe a
very good way to kind of tease out the
Arc of history from a collection of of
disperate documents now as a practical
matter you know one's really talking
about sort of embeddings and vect
databases and all this kind of thing
because you can't just sort of put that
uh you know a trillion words into the
kind of say okay llm here's a trillion
words digest this you have to do that
either as a matter of training or as
something that um is just really
searching for an individual thing but in
any case I think it will be the the
automated histor in is I think going to
be more of a thing I I don't know how
good it will be I mean I've certainly
noticed in my own history and and trying
to piece together histories of things uh
history usually there is a narrative I I
really usually there's a reason things
happened it isn't just the case that
somebody just suddenly one day boom they
they had this idea they did something
there was a whole trail of things that
you can sort of figure out that led them
to that moment LED them to that thing
people rarely and and in the world
things us usually there's a buildup
before things happen it's not just a
suddenly this happened to happen and I
think part of the story of History ends
up being finding that narrative finding
that sort of Arc of history that goes
beyond just the this happened this
happened this happened uh and and I
think that's something that is lots of
work but the very fact that there is all
this data makes it much more realistic
to knit together those arcs of history
and get them right I mean I certainly
know it not not to say that isn't a lot
of work I don't know how much the llms
will be able to help but the um uh you
know that that is the thing you get now
in terms of of uh there are other issues
about sort of the historical record
what's uh what's preserved how like for
example one one example medical records
for instance there are ones from from
Wars and like there are ones from World
War II there are ones from the Gulf War
turns out the ones from the Gulf War are
in much poorer shape than the ones from
World War II the ones from World War II
are on paper and they're sitting in some
archive somewhere and people can go and
look at them it's kind of a nuisance to
to fish all that stuff out but it does
exist the ones from like the Gulf War
apparently you know they were all on
computers and when the computers came
back from the war somebody said well
let's recycle these computers and they
erased all the data so that's a danger
with digital data that it is in a sense
it's sort of easy easier to store
physical stuff maybe if you don't lose
it if the place doesn't burn down and so
on maybe than to store digital stuff I
mean my own experience of storing
digital stuff is well don't don't be too
clever with the formats point1 and point
two keep everything in active storage uh
you know I I just recently I had a
floppy disc an 8 inch floppy disc very
obscure kind of floppy disc and and
somebody was kind enough to uh the
Computer History mus actually to um uh
to be able to actually get most of the
data some of it had not survived from
that 8in floppy disc but that was a that
was a a tiresome thing to do I mean I
got that floppy disc in
1982 and by now it's really unreadable
except at A History A Computer History
Museum so uh that's a reason but if I
kept that data in fact I had kept that
data as it turned out in online form
then that data as it as it sort of gets
transferred from online storage to
online storage and so on that's
something that you can expect to
preserve into the future well unless you
know the discs get blown up or or
whatever else um and and and perhaps it
is the case nowadays with sort of
distributed cloud storage and this and
that and the other that one can be
fairly confident that that data will
survive the next question is will that
data be exposed or will that data be
encrypted uh you know I had the
experience my first big computer system
S&P that I built in 1979 to
1981 um in a piece of modernity I
encrypted the source code and of course
everybody forgot the key and it was
decrypted about so nearly 10 years ago
now uh by Crypt analysis um but uh that
was a case where yes you know you have
everything in digital form it could
still not be accessible because it could
be encrypted and uh I I suspect the
encryption we have today will last a
long time I I don't believe the it's all
going to be broken by quantum computers
partly because I don't really believe in
in quantum computers as such um and uh
you know I think that the the
combinatorics of are on one side in in
the case of encryption and so you know
there will be things where yes it exists
we have the data we have the bits but
it's encrypted and there'll be also
cases where there's a sort of more and
more complicated set of questions about
sort of digital uh privacy kinds of
things and what can be sort of put
together to form the net of history and
what cannot you know the Census Bureau
for example in the US has the rule that
after 70 years a census becomes public
and it's it's sort of carefully
protected before then but then 70 years
later it's public and uh I guess that's
four score years and 10 was thought to
be you know kind of it's all over by
that time it's kind of like like things
where people have 99e leases for land
it's like everybody who made that deal
is dead by the time that the thing blows
up in one's face type thing um it's uh
but this um this question of sort of
what will be exposed and when is an
interesting question which certainly
will affect what future historians can
do um but I do think that the the raw
material is much more easily available
and the the fact that there's such a
high volume of it as we can use more and
more computational tools we more and
more become able to do this sort of
computational history I mean I myself
have done a fair amount of that I think
there's all sorts of interesting
methodology around really using using
computers and computation I mean wolin
language is a is a great tool for doing
this kind of the best I think uh by
because you you get to sort of do all
this kind of multimodal work between
images and and numerical data and text
and kind of use machine learning pick
out uh you know recognize dates and
documents things like this make
timelines make uh sort of networks of of
who was talking to who and so on it's
really really cool and there's much more
that can be done in in those
directions
um let's
see uh 420 asks um doesn't copyright law
allow flexibility with people who want
to share their Works online well yeah
you can absolutely say uh you can say in
um I'm just giving this to the world I'm
putting this in the public domain or I'm
using the Creative Commons you know some
standardized license to say it's
available anybody can use it I do that
with lots of stuff I I produce it's like
anybody can use it but uh you've got to
say where it came from for instance the
um uh copyright was uh the burn
Convention of 1900
was the thing that sort of really uh
sort of organized copyright I mean there
was sort of there were vestages of
copyright earlier than that but that was
the thing that um uh was really the the
sort of international agreement of there
being a copyright it always used to be
written in words copy space right you
know I think it's a constant of history
that word smoosh I'm always telling this
to our dqa document quality assurance
folk when they try and correct words
like website back years ago they were
like website is two words and I said it
won't stay two words it's going to end
up as one word and you know this is a a
principle of smooshing in words and it
happened to copyright as well but um I
think the US even today is not a is not
part of this burn convention but it's
it's um uh there are kind of this notion
that you get uh a certain unique right
in your works is a notion that
well let's see patents which were a
different kind of thing they originated
in the 1600s I believe in England at
first and then were sort of enshrined
even in the US Constitution um but
that's really for inventions as opposed
to sort of creative Works um I think the
uh sort of one thing that was sort of
entangled with copyright I suppose was
the right to print things and you know
certain places had a certain had
licenses to print certain kinds of
things I mean I think this has been true
in the uh um more totalitarian countries
this kind of idea of you know does the
government give you a license to print
this or that thing has been a big deal
it was a big deal in the Soviet Union
it's so you know in modern times you
know in in China for example it's kind
of like can you have this website do you
have the government certification to
have this website I mean different
countries have handled this differently
and the US for example if you want to
own a television station up until
recently maybe even still today there
are all kinds of constraints on what
what you have to all sorts of government
constraints if you want to have a
television station because kind of the
idea is well gosh that's something where
you can really sort of have a an effect
on the country by having using your
television station it sort of raises all
these questions about well you know now
that social media can have an effect you
know what should the government be doing
about that and uh well I'm not usually a
big believer in in all sorts of
complicated regulations but uh uh the I
think um you know that the the issues
have come up again and again and they
come up in different countries in
different ways but sort of the origins
of copyright had to do I think in part
with those kinds of questions and and
you know for example in in England I
know that uh the license to print the
Bible was only given to I think Oxford
University press and Cambridge
University press for for a long time and
that was sort of a a you know the the
that was not quite the copyright on the
Bible it's not clear you know I'm not
sure that King James quite had that um
had that copyright for the King James
version of the Bible and you know the
original uh very unclear who would have
considered that they might have had the
copyright to that um you know I think uh
um one can um but in any case that was
sort of a constraint imposed by the
government on who could print these
things and I think that sort of uh you
know led to an idea that there was a
sort of constraint on what could be done
um I think that uh um if you had I mean
like for instance I think Shakespeare's
plays were printed all sorts of people
printed those and it was like whoever
you know can get to it can do it and
then you would sell them and I don't
think that there was a you know I don't
think Shakespeare could come and say no
you can't do that I have a a right of uh
you know a right associated with copying
um and uh but you know modern copyright
law basically 1900 is is the time when
that um that came in and uh uh it really
hasn't evolved that much since then I
mean I think there were lots of
questions about the copyrightability of
computer code one of the questions is if
you translate from one human language to
another does that kind of Define a new
work where it's kind of a derivative
work and there's all set of definitions
that I think really kind of sort of I
think largely condensed into this
structure sequence organization
definition of whether there is whether
this thing has a structure a sequence an
organization another thing that came up
um we were involved in this in the 1980s
the copyrightability of computer
languages that's different from the
copyrightability of computer code for a
long time it used to be the case that if
you like translated from one computer
language to another then there wasn't
any copyright anymore I'm not sure what
the current legal status of that is that
was a weird thing that I think was was
um was kind of a little bit funky and
perhaps not a great understanding of
what it meant to have a a program and so
on but there are also questions like you
know can you
copyright a um uh well here's a here's a
very basic question can when can you
copyright a number now you might say
that's ridiculous how can you copyright
a number you couldn't copyright the
number 17
because it's just a thing that's out
there all over the place but remember
that any document can be reduced to a
representation as a number and that
number is really just equivalent to the
document so to say I can copyright a
novel is to say I can copyright this
great big long number so now the
question is well how short a number can
you copyright and for instance a haiku
you know short piece of poetry is
something that surely you can copyright
and I have to say in some uh uh various
license management things of ours we
made use of the fact that you can't
legally sort of copy a thing that's
transmitted that happens to be a haiku
um as a as a sort of a form of
copyrightable sort of a minimal
copyrightable element but you know a
haiku is much shorter number now if you
have a number that generates for you
this amazing uh sort of cellular
automatan pattern some rule that um uh
you know generates this amazing pattern
and that number is 14 digits long and
generates this amazing pattern there's a
pretty good argument you can copyright
that number so just how low can it get
and and then that sort of brings in the
question of you know you've got this
number and that number generates this
interesting picture and you know you can
copyright the you know you copyright the
but the picture is generated from the
number by a purely automated process by
by a computer now you may have written
the algorithm by which that that that
thing is generated but there's an
there's an interesting set of questions
about where is the the piece of of
originality creativity and so on and how
much does that matter for copyright
there was a very famous Supreme Court
case in the US the Feist case I believe
which had to do with the copyright
ability of your phone book and the uh
the question was you know a phone book
is clearly and it was arranged
alphabetically so there was no
creativity in the phone book it was
however an original document somebody
had to make it and it had never been
made before and in that particular case
it was ruled that the phone book was
copyrightable that it was sufficient you
did not have to have kind of a creative
spark to have something which was
validly copyrightable and that led to
all kinds of issues about the
copyrightability of data and so on we've
been quite involved in those kinds of
things um and there're rather different
rules in the in the US as compared to
the European union for those types of
things um but uh the um these are these
are sort of questions that have been the
emerging sort of stories of copyright
law now another feature of copyright law
was this idea of copyright libraries of
a place where to have a copyright you
have to deposit a copy of the work in
that Library you know the bodian library
in in the I guess I think there are two
copyright libraries in England I think
it's both the British library and the
bodan library
in the US it's the Library of Congress
and you know in some sort of ways of
setting this up you had to actually send
a copy of your thing there for it to be
validly copyrighted now that's not the
case you can just put that Copyright
symbol and assert that it's copyrighted
and uh you know it depends whether you
actually validly were the originator of
it whether you can validly claim
copyright but the um uh the the the sort
of the thing is if it's sitting in the
Library of Congress and you put put it
there on a certain date and somebody
comes along and says I did this too and
uh and that date when they did it is
when they said they did it is after the
date when you deposited in the Library
of Congress then the Library of Congress
is kind of your blockchain it's kind of
like yes it really existed at that time
you know that that it really was put in
the library at that time and and that's
that's how that works but there sort of
the the um uh very early in the history
of computer software it was uh the the
idea that programs were copyrightable
that was one thing the idea that the
object code the compiled version the
executable was copyrightable that became
a thing very early um I have to say I I
was sort of interestingly involved in
this one I was working at celtech in the
early 1980s and building software there
was this well this is a long story which
perhaps not to to tell right now but but
um uh there was a a whole sort of
meltdown about inter ual property in
which um the uh the bylaws of the
University as the person who was sort of
responsible for this stuff was Keen to
point out to me the bylaws said
copyrightable material is owned by its
authors which meant he didn't have to
try and you know work out what to do
with this intellectual property that we
produced which was software and it's
like well copyrightable material is
owned by its authors copyright software
is copyrightable therefore you own this
you know don't bother us just go start
your own company which is what I did
that was my first company actually um
later that turned into a giant
conflagration of various kinds um that
ended with me uh otherwise I might still
be a professor at celtech all these
years later if it hadn't been for that
particular uh it hadn't been for me uh
quitting in the end but um in any case
the uh that was sort of a you know at
that time again that was early 1980s the
concept that software is copyrightable
was was a thing it wasn't super welln
but it was known know um and you know in
modern times there's sort of a big
question about the copyrightability of
for example generative AI Works um I
think that's been a question that we've
certainly addressed in the past when we
made our W from tones algorithmic music
generation site we have a very we had a
very you tried to do a real analysis of
of that question of sort of who owns
what when it's kind of a a creator of
the algorithm for doing something a
person who pushes the buttons how many
buttons do you have to push before you
really were doing something creative is
that the Criterion is it that you were
doing something merely original if you
search through a large number of
possible interesting cellular automatan
patterns you know we made some nfts from
cellular automaton patterns and did kind
of real-time search through those things
and we're like picking them in in real
time the act of picking is surely a
thing that creates a kind of uh a
copyrightability
potential to the thing just like
somebody who takes a photograph even
though the tree was right there and they
didn't do anything with the tree they
just picked the angle and you know
decided to take the photograph of the
tree so in any case that's um uh that's
uh that's that um
um story I guess um there's a question
here maybe I need to go soon here from
eggy how did legal structures evolve
with the creation of the internet uh
were completely new structures built
because of it um lot of different things
came up with the internet I mean a lot
of things from domain name
registration which was a uh uh that was
something like who can claim this domain
who can claim the domain you know
fish.com how do you register that how
how do you set up a register off for
those kinds of things um that one maybe
was was similar to the uh the concept of
registering the name of a company where
there can only be one of it in a given
state for example and uh uh is different
from trademarks which are established
through use and so on that was just a
let me register this but in terms of the
internet I mean there's just a a
boatload of issues about oh all kinds of
things from you know do people uh when
you have the kind of the the fiber optic
wires of the internet you know do they
does everybody have to carry everybody's
traffic can you have net neutrality do
you force net neutrality where sort of
everybody has to carry everybody's
traffic equally um that was something
that was certainly implied by the sort
of early internet protocols but it's
something that can certainly be debated
um those are those are a few of the
things but just there's just a an
incredible number of of issues that come
up of uh of different kinds of um uh
privacy kinds of things and kinds of
things about well about sort of material
and its copyright ability look one one
of the big ones right now is uh you put
something out on the web and you intend
it for people to read it then an AI
comes through and reads it and trains
itself from what you put on the web for
example it sees the picture that you
painted on the web and it trains itself
from the that picture and five billion
others and then it produces pictures and
some of those pictures have possibly
something which is very reminiscent of
the picture you painted what how does
that sort of uh how does your copyright
to your picture flow through what the AI
saw and so on now we don't imagine that
uh we we think that for example when you
when a human reads something and that
thing thing that they read just goes
into their brain and it it wobbles
around and and they sort of are informed
by having read it I mean certainly I've
spent my life producing things which I
hope inform uh people when they read
them but when people sort of make use of
what they learned from what they read
there's no thread that the law tells
them they have to put back to what I
wrote I mean it's always nice if they
say oh I learned this from you know what
that chat wrote type thing but it's not
as such well with some constraints which
are a different story about sort of the
the kind of the Goodwill you know the
kind of you know who gets to say they
discovered what and things like this but
in any case the the um uh if you on the
other hand if you quote verbatim this
big chunk of stuff then at some length
of thing there's the idea that well
that's a copyrighted thing and you kind
of have to get permission whatever you
have to get the right to to do that
there's this kind of idea that if it's a
short enough quote it's kind of a a fair
use of the thing and and you don't have
to do that and and that's for example on
the web an example of that is thumbnails
on the web it sort of became established
that when you have an image that a
thumbnail is something that you can
fairly use on the web and you don't have
to get elaborate permissions to do that
that's why that's how image search works
you know you see all these thumbnails
and when you click it to get the big
picture you'll typically go to the
website um because that's that's where
it was supposed to be but this question
of of what um kind
of what what does the AI when you are a
provider of pictures for example and you
provide them for human consumption on
the web what does that mean that AI can
do with them and of course that wasn't
imagined at the time when these pictures
were put on the web so it's now a
question of sort of retrofitting that
that set of ideas into a framework that
was really not didn't imagine the
possibility that there would be this
kind of aggregate use of something like
images by by something like an AI and I
think that's a thing that's sort of just
getting hashed out now is for example
you know one thing you make an image
with an AI how much do you own the
copyright to that image
and how much does it matter whether you
touched up the image how much effort you
put into making the image how much does
that all matter that's one thing and the
other thing is if you've put material
out on the web to what extent can you
say well you could say this is for
humans only you could put a thing just
like the robots.txt file can say search
engines shouldn't come in here they
don't always obey the robots.txt file um
that's a a matter for for I mean that's
a technologically they're not blocked uh
you know and I'm not even sure
completely what the legal status of the
robots.txt file is I'm sure that the you
can have kind of a license agreement
associated with the website as a whole
and that probably governs that use and
whether you can include the the material
from the website in a search engine um
but you know the argument was made well
it's good for you to have it in a search
engine otherwise nobody can find your
website um and you know in some cas for
example with news Publications it's like
well is it good to have that in a search
engine or not and you know I think
Google in particular has done some
rather nefarious hacks around many of
these kinds of things uh sort of
avoiding uh you know H sort of dealing
with those kinds of issues um I think
that
um in uh uh this this whole question of
okay it can be ground up by a search
engine that's sort of okay if your
robots.txt fil doesn't say otherwise
well what about if it's ground up by an
AI by an llm dealing with language or by
an image generation system dealing with
images uh you know what point is is what
you know at what point is it is it okay
not okay and and there's some precedents
here with music for example where
there's all of this issue of of mixed
you know um what on Earth are they
called my gosh mixes uh in music where
people will take you know just a few
notes from one song and then there are
cases where people have argued you know
just that sequence of five notes is the
heart of the song and it's subject to
copyright even though it's only five
notes I don't know what the actual
shortest is I'm guessing three or four
notes um and you know that feels like
it's kind of copyrighting the number 17
but it really isn't quite because the
number of comori possibilities is quite
large and and I don't know to what
extent one one takes it as an as a
significant thing how memorable you know
the da da da whatever it is you know the
the the that sequence actually ends up
being but you know that's a thing where
there's sort of this question of to what
extent does the mix thing end up end up
um uh working in um uh how does that
work in the case of music what was done
was there's this oh gosh there are two
of them one is called ASAP and the
other's name I forgotten I'm afraid but
there's this whole mechanism where you
can play music
and but somehow when you play that music
you are giving some small amount of
money to this Central fund which then
redistributes that money to the original
producers of the music and you don't
have to go ask before you play some some
music at your store or something you
don't have to go get specific permission
from the artist who made that piece of
music it goes through this kind of um
Clearing House and and by the way the
same thing you know there's a there's
attempt to do the same with copyright
there's the a company copyright Clearing
House that right which um gosh I haven't
seen them being used for a long time now
but but that's a place where for example
if you're going to do something where
you're giving out things for some class
at some University or something and
you're make making lots of copies which
would be potentially a violation of
copyright um you can just say well I'm
I'm doing this and I'm I'm doing it
through the copyright clearing house and
I'm giving them you know I'm just
telling them I'm doing it and then you
get a sort of aggregated bill for all
the things that you did that had various
kinds of uh uh you don't have to
independently negotiate I mean when when
you know it is a kind of a a slightly um
uh slightly frictional thing that people
you know people are reproducing you know
very often I mean on a pretty much daily
basis people uh are you know interested
in reproducing some picture that made
that I put in some some place and they
want to print it in some book and we get
some requests saying can we print this
in a book and we say sure with these
conditions and so on but it's kind of a
thing where where the publishing company
has to kind of contact the individual
author to get that permission uh whereas
there is sort of this this idea like
what happens with music you don't have
to do that where there's this kind of
centralized mechanism and and clearly
for the internet if you've got an AI
that looked at five billion images the
thought of kind of going back to all of
those image uh creators and sort of how
that works is is a very it'd be very
difficult to uh to do that and and even
more so that it's kind of like you've
made an image of a cat and the question
is of all of the 3,000 cat artists or
even cat photographs that you got from
the web which one was the most
contributive to that image that the AI
produced you know which cat should be
fed the most you know the the most
stylish cat food as compensation for the
fact that its image was used in by the
AI by this weight in the neural net this
collection of you know 100 million
weights in the neural net that all in
some microscopic way encoded the
particular whiskers of that particular
cat it's very hard to see how you
disentangle that it's very interesting
problem actually this kind of credit
assignment to sort of inut data I think
it's a very difficult one I think
there's sort of a general question of is
there a a calculus of derivative works
that is I I have thought about this
actually to some extent because I think
it relates to some sort of core
computational issues if you are doing
something like you're in a in a video
game and you're designing for some
reason an example I've used in the past
is a dinosaur headdress and you know you
have the basic dinosaur headdress and
then you modify the dinosaur headdress
and the question is what you know the
person who originally designed that
thing they own certain rights copyright
type rights and then as you modify it
you are gradually pulling it away from
that original form and uh you know
there's a question of to what extent can
the original Creator prevent you from
doing that and say it has to be this
particular you know dinosaur headress I
think in the EU there are some Notions
in the law of of moral rights and so on
where where the where the original
producer of something can exert more
more sort of you know you can't if your
photo if your picture is going to be
used in some uh setting which you find
horrifying you can say you can't do that
even though the person bought the
picture and but that's not I think a a
concept in in US law for instance and I
think the um uh there's this sort of
question of it can you imagine a sort of
calculus of derivative works that
establishes kind of of what uh you know
how much is this person responsible for
this final thing and that obviously
depends on well if you change that you
know uh sort of the the green eye of the
dinosaur to a yellow eye is that a
critical thing or not and sort of an
interesting question and it relates to
core questions about meaning and so on
you know can you assign different levels
of significance to different aspects of
the message so to speak it kind of
relates to the we were talking about
much earlier about information Theory
and the encoding of messages anyway you
guys have taken me Far Far a field here
but um uh I hope uh you found that
interesting it's always uh useful to me
to try and sort of crystallize thoughts
about different kinds of things and I'm
sure I forgot and uh and Miss said many
things uh as I was talking about these
kind of legalistic issues um but uh
hopefully people um uh found that of
Interest so thanks for thanks for
joining me and uh talk to you another
time bye for
now